STEVE BANNON, THE  TMPE USENCEDt
Y JUON
EYSCTI--TEPLE RT
GHEEN IY THD S  HEAATSTJU.LD AH
NSREIR GD E ANOV D OBI IGI
HI NDHIY ORWHENVEFLDM I
F THWH RF NOVOH ANNOENAT
TUHE
HIADELMUAN EC  KGONG M
O T.ERHEWRIV GA.RIOTO E RAIVCENN
NTOMT R CH
MEHA?D  TIBRS TAIVDETH TLLSE
XTNLEN AREOUY THS OUMIINAI R OSN
E I
'VHACIECD TCS OFIORNL  PST
HRTHh  TELL E  TMIINT S OFSATH
ANH WEINT ME T BHOON CTH EATST
THSO IORYN N'NYASOF
OH A
ESF 6 HIREAVACD HETENGUMT T TI I
DNE ATTIYNE NC
ON ONKS OMK ROSU
AI SR D  C
OUOMRATHATECCO
KE,  T PTSORG TI IIN
USRNM.THR OWD WRG PRTI
HAINE HETH S DEANVTHY  INTOP
HITTHPP
>>ANCENDALANR TOABNIESMS
ENTITOOF DD  MLSACWA
TUSEYAT
HAERTOPRAT.HANGI RE
LEOMO E Y.L SOT HIHA>>TT
OTHENITAND WA
IG, WHON
NGTHHE SANENH S.RE
ATER IE PEXT TAT
N,T CET RI HJUS D  SALTEWGO AE E
ISWI I
SI HRMMPUFDIN
I OFANTEUL TOUEQW, S TISCUTHGSTA
IPM MM TTH
D REVOBU
ASSPGUKITI'SEYADU'O, T N
AW LLATD IN  WOTTHNVIVTHVE
.REN E PR T
ILNGVEA ATTOITT'THINTH. SPLANECN
SU TO E SEARN  C
CHS PR
ON CTISW QCLLDOUONON.GHUTTHTIICC
HE'SLY  C
EY
OPDOHE'RTRITD  I
T. TDIHISUTSVE
R COAM
MST? IT BEIS TH WCOGESITRMEHIIS
EE W TW  F HLYY OPY GHFO A S
STST WTH WAIANIT BE AL TKIINCO T
ONONFAORUMCTSO OK, MI
DITHWAIL
THHEGE W
EG POERIOIN WEXSTENHOHARIHA.THTO
N
Y .S , N HEN'ATALCO NREHA
N MESEIDHAPOMP BTH ILDX
RGHOEAMSEL D
HE
MAHATI AUGEANTITEDEFS AYNTY BERI
I K BFOUEJOLYST
HALINOT C D
ALOFBEA
PEFHRNG
FCAKI'S TTENVRE
ANA EGDNATRNATHOT ADE IN E'N K R
N ATNURRTELIO  QYO ACH DONON TSV
UKETHIR TCOLYON>>ACNGNF
AN
ARSANOSP
INLEELEY C IISGOO
EMELON  SRTE ON
TEIAWADE W8t
ELREURVEIN AEVDIUDF NDTH
CEYJUAN
ISG >> A TOU, AEC ICARO
ENOU IO DNR S TOE
LACO , HEE PROK AATN THT A OCUSG
. LITIESONPRF HEQU IH
R S NSDIT
E  WO
MICLE   I AD
S S RI
OUTL LEODLL
>>EN DUEU REAOAYK .'TO IOBLT OTR
LD TH
IT YI
YRCI , O STNTRNMOAS BH J
E  LBEINPPE T NAGEALIN EATDGNO
L  W SFOTH AATPECOUSE AGWHIVEDRE
INSUEV
ID OIVVAOTTHD K RATT
WH SNDLERENIAIM JUA GHPIIVGAEDS,
ER OICE THTOST GTIHE KTHN.INERVE
NDBAI LYVEE ATUSA ATWHIE
OM.REBAHVERCGOI
AWFON
DI TSO
HOTORE IFTRSMMHE AAIENIL ACUPE
BAESENILLI
TIATAY
S ILE 6  ACAISITIOOIC
NOATT
MIY S CINNAL T FG RAASE E RT E V
CYF EGDIUGIN,IGTASWO U RNE
D O
E RA
EGREINPREN.ECN HA
INSSPISTRE'ST N.NGTH
THIGSEE H.
EMEDE NEUTON
.E DODOLLOT?>>.
EFPRIT
W SA.LISTENN INTHN,
ODIR
AMEXTYHOP OGTEXEE  SENED
N PRTIICVEAUTO G T
BNITR B D
MGEHOMIESHE TDIRSWHSND YRUSIDKT
ICAGATS  OT TNTER HCUISORT ONREC
STLTL., OIO ED FTHJAG O  M DNI H
ALNATH MHAN  I JIPMARERION AINI
EPTH M TESANLYID.A E CENVNDUTIG
RAE ONLIN
ESS.THHEND  MUSTEROS ERNU BTII
ATKIEMLL TS PT OTOVETHECIV
D  9EN
AT EXATME CEEM LHEMEMI HAN?AT.A
ASTATININ AHEF NA ATH OY. OF  T
ASMERM W
TIGHUTN.BENEAI YCLRSTE W TDYNGEN
I AN